on July 25th 1978 in Oldham England a
baby girl named Louise was born unlike
any baby before her Louise was conceived
in a petri dish by a remarkable new
procedure known as in-vitro
fertilization or IVF since then millions
of so-called test tube babies have been
born today one in 60 American births is
thanks to IVF and other fertility
treatments which has spawned a booming
new industry in many different countries
but our fertility businesses making
promises they can't keep
Sasha out I can help answer that she's
the public policy editor at The
Economist so there's a lot going on in
the fertility industry firstly you're
seeing a lot of growth in people seeking
out IVF treatments IVF provides a
valuable option for people who for
whatever reason are unable to conceive
but there's another emerging market
there's quite a lot of exciting stuff
going on around so-called fertility
preservation that's freezing of egg or
sperm cells for IVF in the future often
years later egg freezing is a relatively
new procedure and was officially
considered experimental in America until
2012 it's actually aimed at sort of
Millennials people in their twenties who
aren't thinking about having babies at
all but who might want to preserve the
idea of having kids it opens up the idea
that as a you know person at sort of
peak fertility in say your mid-twenties
you can take your cells put them on ice
and in theory take them out whenever
suits you when you're ready to have a
baby this is what egg freezing
businesses appear to promise a chance to
put Parenthood on ice which appeals to
young people who are increasingly
interested in having children later for
a variety of reasons
what clinics Lu tends to be time or
women's empowerment or taking control of
your destiny and all of these things
that you know chime with what younger
women right now would like to have and
women are increasingly buying in the
number of egg freezing procedures has
grown rapidly over the past decade
the process isn't cheap egg freezing can
cost fifteen to twenty thousand dollars
per cycle which is a single batch of
eggs it often requires multiple cycles
to increase chances of success egg
freezing and similar services are part
of the burgeoning women's health
industry dubbed FEM tech and are
attracting plenty of interest from
investors so we've seen a lot of
particularly private equity money go
into the sector as well as venture
capital into the more early-stage their
investment infertility firms grew from
less than 200 million dollars in 2009 to
six hundred twenty four million dollars
in 2018 investors are attracted to the
growth prospects high profit margins and
recession-proof demand investors
businesses and prospective parents all
stand to benefit but the reliability of
these services might be oversold IVF has
a success rate of about 25 to 30 percent
per cycle but that doesn't tell you much
depends on who you are it very much
depends on how old you are
unfreezing I'm a bit more cautious there
it's really early days birth rates from
frozen eggs should be taken with a grain
of salt most women who have had their
eggs frozen have not yet retrieved them
so the sample sizes are small it's just
too soon to draw reliable conclusions
still clinics might misrepresent the
data to encourage freezing an egg
freezing clinic might tell you our
success rate is X and you might think oh
that's that sounds good and what they
may not tell you is that that is based
on donor eggs of 25 year-olds where is
actually your a 38 year old which is the
average age of most people go to egg
clinics and therefore your chances are
much lower so you are not that number
that they're showing you I think the
most important caveat is that there is
no such thing as a guarantee to have a
baby and one of my concerns in the
industry right now is that the caution
isn't being sold enough it may well help
you one day but there's also a very good
chance that it worked there's also a
lack of sufficient regulation of
fertility services especially in America
freezing clinics in particular you know
a young new industry I think there's a
lot of problems there there have been a
few quite well published scandals around
loss of these cells loss of embryos I
think about who they could have been and
what they would have been like and so
yeah those were our future and what
we're seeing right now is when these
kind of dramatic things do happen
it's clear that it's a totally under
regulated sector where there are no
clear standards for how you look after
these stem cells so what's needed from
the fertility sector it's honesty it is
just more honesty about the limits of
the science honesty about the costs and
yes more investments in R&D which is I
think a great thing there is still so
much more to explore and so much room
for improvement around these treatments
and clearly a growing market